foreign
lover of ladies and unrivaled cook a
member of the monster Trio along with
Luffy in Zorro and a former Prince to
boot unlike his captain Luffy and rival
Zorro sanji's strength may not be
obvious but with innate intelligence
unshakable loyalty and an uncanny sense
of pulling off Feet's integral to the
crew's survival sanchi is definitely the
third strongest of the straw hat Pirates
and when the smooth Suave cigarette
smoking Dandy kicks ass he sure does
make our hearts flutter so hang on to
your seats for here goes sanji's top 10
most badass moments
foreign
spot Sanji takes a direct hit from God
and L to protect his crewmates in the
sky peer Arc Ade
onboard The Arc Maxim Nami is stranded
with enel a formidable enemy who uses
the logia power of lightning meanwhile
usop has already been Zapped and is one
step away from being killed that's when
Sanji courageous to a false steps in
that he's been defeated once before by
NL doesn't stop him from rushing
headlong into almost certain death
having taken the full brunt of the blast
directed at usof Sanji terribly singed
but still standing takes a long drag
from his cigarette and warns NL to get
ready to cry moments before losing
Consciousness now he always puts the
safety of his friends first even if
great risk to himself is what makes him
a true hero in our eyes
a testament to his strength and
Ingenuity and number nine we have Sanji
make mincemeat a fish magurobi early on
in the AR Long Park Arc Ade
trying to save his captain Luffy from
drowning Sanji Dives in after him only
to be pursued by the arlong Pirates
henchmen and in fact it's impossible for
an average human to be a fish man
underwater Sanji 2 has a tough time
countering gurobi's blows and dealing
with the deadly water pressure however
with his resourcefulness and intelligent
use of knowledge as a cook Sanji cuts
off gurobi's Air Supply and emerges the
Victor in a fight that should have
clearly worked to his disadvantage as an
early example of his quick thinking and
cleverness scientists fight in arlong
park endures still something
at number eight Sanji aka Mr Prince
saves his crew from a watery grave in
arabaster
stranded in a room fast flooding filled
with banana wani which are ginormous
alligators with a banana shaped
protrusion on their heads and knocked in
a cage of sea Stone Luffy and Company
are helpless from amidst the cacophony
of desperate cries comes a Suave voice
and in the next moment a banana wani is
ko'd Sanji in characteristic star Saves
the Day by appearing out of the blue in
his Cruise darkest hour and my what an
entrance it is the only known predator
of the sea Kings but nanawani are not
just hulking Giants but extremely Savage
booting one so hard that you see it
bounce right up is a testament to
sanji's monstrous awe-inspiring strength
also noteworthy is the allusion to his
princely Heritage way way before sanji's
bloodline is revealed in the whole cake
Island dog
foreign
Sanji faces the ruthless Virgo at Punk
hazard in what is now clearly a pattern
Sanji has a pretty woman to rescue in
this fight too
so on one side is dashiki a marine
Captain whose tears call out to the hero
in Sanji on the other side is Virgo an
elite officer of the Don Quixote family
posing as a naval vice admiral despite
both contestants not being devil fruit
users this Clash doesn't lack in
Firepower in fact it's a breathtaking
display of martial arts in which Sanji
lives up to his black leg moniker
despite the odds Sanji sends the
powerful Virgo crashing twice and much
their surprise he rescues dashiki and
her Fallen Marine comrades making his
kind and honorable side apparent amidst
ringing Applause from the G5 unit the
pirate cook saves the day as well as the
Damsel in Distress
Strikers
trumping a painful past and betrayal by
his family and fiancee sanji's singular
kindness makes it to the number six spot
as he rescues his family in the whole
cake island arc
the third son of the VIN smoke family of
German Kingdom Sandy's coerced into
marrying Charlotte pudding yonko big
mom's daughter a gentleman to the court
Sanji known full world that the wedding
is a farce not only forgives pudding for
her betrayal but also protects her from
her cruel siblings in an arc tailor-made
for him Sanji shows his family next that
he's not the weakling that labeled him
as despite being pitched against big
mom's oldest son a fearsome candy
manipulator Sanji manages to rescue the
family the once in prison and abandoned
him when he was but a child this is
sanji's first major moment after the
two-year time Skip and we can see his
martial arts has grown exponentially in
power This Moment's Forever emblazoned
in our memory
at the halfway mark now we have another
momentous instance of sanji's
mind-boggling prowess in martial arts
prior to his training in kamabaka
Kingdom during the time skip Sanji faces
off against Oz a zombie giant
resurrected by the warlord gecko Moria
teaming up with some of his crewmates
are curly brown cook tackles The
Towering foe who seems impossible to
defeat impeccable teamwork catches the
giant off guard and dangerously
unbalanced on one foot before he can
steady himself though Sanji with just a
standard attack of his black leg style
brings down oars flipping him upside
down and sending massive shockwaves
around the ship a slant above his kick
in the whole cake Island Saga this one
stands out more for its destruction
level without the use of haki or Raid
suits thus proving Sanji worthy of his
inclusion in the monster Trio
work
towel
if it's Sanji then we must allow for a
certain degree of frivolity as much as
he exudes raw power nothing Spurs him on
more than a beauty in trouble so for our
fourth pick we have Sanji versus egg
strike in wano country
foreign
s into a dinosaur and attacks Sanji in
the midst of being thrashed around
santi's lascivious antenna picks up a
distress call from the lovely comurasaki
throughout the one piece Saga sanji's
first and foremost a ladies man prone to
succumbing to their charms incapable of
pulling off impressive Feats in their
name and just like that Drake's brought
down in a Trice with a barrage of
flaming kicks to the head for a
relatively short fight the speed at
which Sanji executes his attacks is
overwhelming in fact with Zorro tackling
yoshiro at the end sanji's fight with
Drake draws up a nice contrast pity
though that he's bested by Zorro in
rescuing komurasaki much to his Chagrin
foreign
up the heat we have the legendary
martial arts matchup between the lying
wolf giabura and the hunter Sanji at
number three
the enemies Lobby Arc is one of the best
in the series and wrought with emotion
as Nico Robin faces death pinning Our
Hope on Sanji he never disappoints
against an opponent who like him is the
third strongest in his crew this contest
lives on in our memory as one of sanji's
very best things don't start off well
for Sanji before jio Buddha he goes up
against a female cp9 agent and suffers a
humiliating defeat thanks he is an
ability to fight a woman as a matter of
principle but against yabuda he does
more than redeem himself this is also
the fight in which he unleashes Diablo
jumbay for the first time a flaming
attack star that gives Sanji his
trademark Red Hot Leg sanji's battle
against the hybrid wolf is undeniably
one of his strongest Showcases of power
well before the time skip
over there
in the runners-up spot kicking up the
storm is our favorite fight between
Sanji and Prima ballerina Mr tubong Clay
an officer agent of Baroque Works born
Clay is one of the trickiest opponents
sanji's ever encountered while the two
are evenly matched Von clay has a
definite advantage over the love cook
his devil fruit ability allows him to
copy another's appearance which he uses
to great effect against Sanji by
transforming into the gorgeous Nami
given his refusal to fight women Sanji
yet again suffers severe damage at the
hands of the enemy thankfully much more
quick richer than Luffy or Zorro Sanji
easily finds a [ __ ] in Bon Clay's armor
though it by no means gives him an easy
Victory this is one of the most exciting
battles in the series the sense of
camaraderie between the two elevating
the contest to the next level what
begins as enmity blooms into a rare
friendship between Von clay and the
straw hats to the point where the former
sacrifices himself to help Luffy Escape
impul down later on in the series
yes
and it's time for our winning entry
Sanji goes head to head with Dobby Ropo
page one an ancient zoan type dinosaur
in the flower Capital page one wreaks
Havoc looking for sanagoro who is
actually Sanji in Disguise the moment
we've all been waiting for unfolds
swallowing his pride Sanji dons the raid
suit given to him by his family ever
righteous he'd rather use the German
technology to save innocent lives and
hang on to his past of course he refuses
to identify a stealth black instead
naming himself osoba mask contrary to
the Goofy name Sanji makes quite an
impact stronger faster and almost
invulnerable to physical attacks he even
survives crashing through an entire row
of houses with barely a scratch taking
inspiration from Superhero
Transformations sanji's metamorphosis is
fun especially for Frankie and usop
cheering in the shadows
and that brings us to the end of today's
video this is Vinnie tube bringing you
the top 10 badass Sanji moments stay
tuned for more of course don't forget to
like comment and subscribe to my channel
if you like this video and I'd love to
hear from you as well so type away in
the comments below see you next time
with more exciting anime and one piece
content ciao